it is one of the deadliest series of
police raids ever even for Brazil
several people were left dead as civil
and military police targeted drug
traffickers in a poor Rio neighborhood
where residents say heavy gunfire began
Wednesday morning
police say they encountered intense
opposition on arrival
we were met by many gunshots in intense
armed confrontation ensued And We
rescued nine criminals who died on their
way to hospital a military police member
was wounded and was transferred to the
military police hospital and is in
stable condition
in these poor Urban favelas of Brazil
it's not uncommon in recent days to see
armored police and military vehicles in
the streets leaving wounded and
hospitalized behind police insist they
face aggressive armed resistance by drug
gangs recovering seven rifles ammunition
and grenades in the Rio raid which they
say demonstrates the Arsenal they face
but the shootings have increased
controversy in a region where critics
say police are quick to kill and mostly
poor afro-brazilian neighborhoods
Justified or not the Spate of killings
by police is striking even in a country
that is notorious for violence by
authorities John hendren Al Jazeera
foreign